der mond ist in den letzten mehreren
hundert millionen jahren geschrumpft und
das nicht zu knapp
dabei hat er 50 metern durchmesser
eingebüßt jetzt steht fest dass dieser
schrumpfungsprozess des erdtrabanten
weiter geht stück für stück wird unser
mond also immer kleiner und rumpelt
dabei zusammen wie eine weintraube zur
rosine
und das hat folgen stichwort mond beben
und die sollen bald genauer untersucht
werden krieg zum science fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierend des
seins videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen schon vor neun jahren gab es
erste hinweise darauf dass der mond
immer kleiner wird und das schon seit
mehreren hundert millionen jahren durch
die detaillierte analyse von aufnahmen
des nasa lunar reconnaissance orbiter
lro konnte ein us forschungsteam jetzt
neue super spannende erkenntnisse dazu
gewinnen demnach ist der mond kleiner
geworden weil er in der vergangenheit
innerlich stück für stück abgekühlt ist
in den zeiten seiner entstehung vor
knapp 4,5 milliarden jahren war der mond
also deutlich heißer und kühlt somit
also nach und nach aus der mond
schrumpft zusammen quasi wie eine
weintraube zu rosine schrumpeln denn der
schrumpfungsprozess sorgt für falten
klippen und spalten auf seiner
oberfläche eine art geologisches rund
sind also dadurch hat er übrigens schon
an durchmesser verloren und zwar etwa 50
meter doch nicht nur das weil der mond
an größe verliert kommt es dort immer
wieder zu erdbeben oder mond beben die
erde des mondes b diese erkenntnis ist
allerdings nicht wirklich neu hinweise
darauf kamen schon von den astronauten
der apollo mission in den 60er und 70er
jahren die teams der missionen 12 14 15
und 16 hatten insgesamt vier seismometer
auf dem mond installiert die dann
zwischen 1969 und 1977 insgesamt 28 mond
beben registriert hatten auf der erde
hätten diese beben eine stärke zwischen
2 und 5 grad ein teil dieser beben wurde
wohl durchaus so ihnen einschläge
verursacht doch sicher nicht alle doch
wie kamen die anderen erschütterungen
zustande die fachleute hatten sich für
die aktuelle analyse die historischen
aufzeichnungen noch einmal genauer
angeschaut und dabei festgestellt dass
sich acht der damals 28 registrierten
beben in der nähe geologischen junger
bruchzonen
haben dazu nicolas schwer der an der
studie beteiligt war
wir haben festgestellt dass eine reihe
der beben aus den apollo aufzeichnungen
sich sehr nahe an den bruchzonen aus
zehn lro aufnahmen ereignet haben
die acht mond beben ereigneten sich
demnach höchstens 30 kilometer von
solchen buch zonen entfernt dazu ergänzt
studienleiter thomas waters wir halten
es für sehr wahrscheinlich dass diese
acht beben von brüchen verursacht wurden
die abgerutscht sind nachdem sich eine
spannung in der mondkruste durch die
globale kontraktion und gezeitenkräfte
aufgebaut hatte die aufnahmen des nasa
lunar reconnaissance orbiters zeigen
dass das gesteinsmaterial um diese buch
zone neu aussieht unterlassen die
fachleute deswegen vermuten dass sie
erst in jüngerer zeit entstanden sind
laut der expertin experten vor weniger
als 50 millionen jahren was biologisch
gesehen tatsächlich eine eher kleine
zeitspanne ist auch die erdbewegungen
die damals nachgewiesen werden konnten
sprechen nach ansicht der expertinnen
und experten dafür dass diese bruchzonen
auch heute noch aktiv sind zudem legt
die auswertung von mehr als 12.000
bilder nahe dass sich das becken mare
frigo riss in der nähe des mond nordpols
verschiebt und brüche zeigt dabei waren
fachleute lange zeit davon ausgegangen
dass es dort keine geologische bewegung
gibt den klartext heißt das also dass
der mond nicht nur immer kleiner wird
sondern auch weiterhin tektonisch aktiv
ist eine super spannende erkenntnisse
auch für das forschungsteam selbst dazu
thomas waters man bekommt nicht oft
irgendwo außerhalb der erde aktive
tektonik zu sehen daher ist es sehr
spannend darüber nachzudenken dass diese
brücke vielleicht immer noch mond reden
produzieren darum ganz sicher zu gehen
will das forschungsteam jetzt einen
vorschlag erarbeiten wie eine neue
mission ein ganzes netzwerk an modernen
seismographen auf dem mond platzieren
könnte denn klar ist für zukünftige mond
besucher und besucherinnen ist es gut zu
wissen welche gegenden man meinen sollte
der mond seine entstehung und der
forschung anklicken anschauen und
raumzeit block der zukunft abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran